I was wondering was there a moment where
you got like interested in acting cuz
you when we've talked to leis you
haven't talked about much about like
your path into trying to be an actor I
just know you tried to be one well tried
there was some successes in there it's
I'm not a complete flame out where I
just tried and um yeah it was it was
during it was during middle school and
like high school when I had a lot of
trouble because I wasn't in the normal
classes for a different reasons but I
found theater as like a thing where I
could be really challenged with some of
the it's really hard to be a a stage
actor because oh I'm sure and I took it
really seriously and so after high
school where I I learned that oh it's
not just shouting when you're angry or
emoting when you're sad when I went to
college it was pretty formative and I I
worked actually I got hired at a radio
station as a DJ like right out of high
school and that was really hard because
the people I worked with were so awful
it probably the worst job experience
I've ever had M how are they awful just
well rude this is a this is a six minute
story is that okay
it's yeah yeah I wish it had a funny
ending but oh well so basically I was
taking a broadcasting class in college
and there was this amazing weatherman
for the local news who was teaching it
and his advice was like if you ever get
your foot in the door don't take it out
because these opportunities are hard to
come by sure and I was like that does
make a lot of sense and then there was a
radio station in Kansas City called
z95.7 today's hit music [__] music and
then uh you they came into our our class
to give like the morning show DJ and the
morning shows in America are the most
popular because you get like you're in
traffic and it's a lot of like joking
and talking and less music so they came
F sounds of fart sounds and sound
effects and yes GTA radio but exactly
and he came in and I was something came
up where he was like yeah it's pretty
hard to get into radio but if you do
it's a lot rewarding and I was like well
I kind of want to get into it and he was
like sorry kid we're not hiding I was
like well I just want to come and like
see the studio can I just come see it he
was like all right why don't you come in
next Tuesday and you can take a look at
how we do the morning show and it's like
a thing and I was like cool so I went in
the next Tuesday and I thought it was
amazing they had like these huge ass
boards they were telling jokes the whole
time there was Dave and shorty and a guy
named Twiggy fat saxs which is a
horrible name but like was that really
his that Twiggy yes uh this is none of
this is made up
and at the very end of their episode
they said well we do have a special
guest here today uh some kid from the
the local community college do you want
to come in and say something and I had
like I had to take the extra mic and I
was and I made like I don't know what
joke I made but I said something that
was funny and everyone kind of laughed
and the show ended and I said that was
amazing uh and the guy said you know why
don't you come back again on Tuesdays
and Thursdays every week you can intern
for us and kind of learn the ropes and I
was like I was like okay yeah once you
get your foot in the you can kind do
this so I started coming in every
Tuesday Thursday and then something
happened where they uh the mid the
midafternoon guy or girl had to go to a
different station or moved out so they
had to replace that person and Twiggy
fat saxs took the took the opportunity
so now I get moved into his position
which is the third mic normally I would
have to stand there for the entire time
and if I had a funny joke that I felt
would be ready I'd go like this and I'd
be like joke and then they' take it away
that was like really high sorry Conor
that was really high take both no but
like but then you're really worried like
this joke better be good because you're
you're requesting like the 19y to come
in and say like a funny thing and uh
then I got moved to the third mic which
was on all the time and I was also the
phone guy who I would take like C 95.7
this is Kramer that was my nickname my
call name was Kramer oh so you were like
on the air while also taking on that one
I could hit a button to mute my my mic
to so i' I'd have to take the call and
they'd say like yeah I want to tell Dave
that I want to have his babies and
you're like okay that's not thank you
very much for calling you know whatever
the Callins and if it was a good call
I'd push it forward and they would take
it on the air right yeah so there was
one disturbing Trend that started to to
develop while we were on this morning
show one it was imagine though if you're
like in Melbourne or London and your
voice is heard to like your buddies at
like 18 19 years old this is like a
crazy opportunity right and like my mom
would be listening at her her dentist
office and she'd be like that's my son
Kramer and it was really like pretty
awesome and but they started to really
use me as a punching bag really really
regularly and then it became like I can
take it let's make self you know
self-deprecating humor I can handle that
and then it started getting kind of
offensive so anytime I would say any
kind of joke like they'd be like who's
the loser who like takes baths and I'd
be like I that's the the lead in yeah I
take baths every time I spoke they would
hit this sound bite and this is kind of
offensive I'm sorry to anybody they'd
say you faery you company man which is a
movie quote from like alpacino right and
it was a derogatory slur to make it
sound like I was not manly or whatever
the joke was and so then it that started
and then each day it got worse with like
making fun of me let's they did a win a
date with Kramer like you know and then
we'd have like the camera crew and they
set it all up and then they had the
camera show there and I showed up to the
thing and they made a big joke saying
nobody signed up for it you're a loser
like and I was like okay and they never
even put it out right so now I'm like
all right what the [__] this is really
bad [__] up it was but this was the this
was like 2003 so I decided I have some
dignity left I I probably should quit
and so I said listen I really appreciate
your guys' opportunity I learned a lot
being on the radio business this past
year I I think it'd be best if I focused
on my studies and they were like that's
good because we were going to fire you
and I was like okay well then that's
that's great all right so what a bunch
of assoles I know and so but I'm So
Young right and I don't know how to to
deal with that would be stressful to
yeah dude it was crazy so I remember
they said here's the idea that we've got
we're going to do a two-day event where
you get made fun of a lot and we're
gonna we're going to pretend that you
blow up on the air and we're going to
get suspended for a weekend so we can go
to Vegas to see a Britney Spears concert
and at first I I I was pretty pressured
I was like okay that sounds good you
know this okay let's just do that and so
the first day we do it I play the part
as I knew I could perfectly I said you
guys I've had enough of every day you're
playing these sound drops or you're
making fun of me or win a date with
Kramer Why don't you win a date with go
yourself you know something like that
yeah and it went really well except I
had an email that was like Kramer
z95.7 for about a year I had like three
emails ever sent to that address and
they were all like uh can you ask out
shorty for me I think she's a babe and
after that episode I had thousands of
emails of people hating me saying that I
didn't appreciate this golden
opportunity to be on the and I was like
it's a joke everybody I thought this was
obvious my mom was concerned she was
like what happened it sounded so real
too good I'm too good so you were too
good good so I told my acting coach I
was like dude I'm pretty nervous I was
like this is not going well I have
people calling my home phone saying that
I'm ungrateful I don't even know how
they found me I'm not in the phone book
as Kramer you know but like and so I
said he was like yeah dude it's [__]
up it's dumb you know what if I if I was
you I'd go in there tomorrow and I'd be
like [__] you I'm not doing your stupid
gag and you can go [__] yourself yeah
and I was like go in there and say [__]
you and go [__] yourself okay I can do
that no I couldn't I I I so I went there
and I was like all right it's my last
day I'm supposed to do this one last
bit and somehow I did get the courage to
to say no but I've never had such a dry
mouth in my entire must been terrified
just completely cuz you know you
obviously raised your whole life being
like don't talk back
and you're in radio right this to me at
the time symbolized some sort of like
Gateway or opportunity the door and I
wanted to to transition to sports radio
and so I was asking for like a
recommendation so like an intern at the
the AM station and I go in there and
they go okay man so we're going to do
this thing and then we're going to uh
we're just going to have you leave but
thanks so much and I was like there's
like two or three minutes before the
show starts and I was
like they're like are you all right and
I was like yeah I was like um actually
I'm not going to go through with it and
they're like you're not going to go
through with what you you can't work
here anymore and I was like no I think
this I think that I think that this joke
is stupid and I don't want to do it and
they were like I'm actually getting
nervous now remembering and like and but
they were like they the girl tore into
me and she was she was really really
ruthless she was like honestly you've
never had an ounce of talent for this
profession and we only kept you until we
found someone better and I was like
that's fine I'm not doing this stupid
joke and she was like you will never
ever work in this town again and I was
like that's
fine I was like oh that's not good I
kind of live here I'm very young and I
was like that's fine you know and I was
like it's not worth it because I I just
don't understand why can't you guys say
we were just joking thank you so much
Peter for your hard work good luck at
the University why can't we have like a
a nice thing and they were like and I
saw Dave he took the the volume control
and he's like we just can't trust you
today and he's I was like [__] you you
know I was like what a loser and I was
feeling really down and they uh they
told me to go sit in theuh corner and
they went live like I was like some bad
kid or something and I was sitting there
and um they had to go to commercial
break and they were kind of just doing
the show as normal and someone called in
and they they put him on but not on air
it was just 95.7 what and it was my
teacher he didn't know was there and he
was like yeah you guys are [__] lame
asses and I think all of you especially
you Dave you [__] hack you're a bunch
of losers and for you to take advantage
of that young man who gave you a year of
your time you know you can go [__]
yourself and that moment I felt like
somebody had in my back this is like a
film I know D was crazy and like and he
was they're like you know we're not
going to put he's like I don't want to
be on the [__] air I have some
dignity I don't want to be on z95 point
[__] off and I was like
so when when that guy was going hard and
then I I I was just like [__] it I'm out
my left and I just walked out and like
it ended and I thought for sure well
that's it that's acting reron Ronis but
I felt um after that I felt like
embracing failure was actually more of
an important lesson to learn than it is
to earn people's like Ovation and like
totally so by embracing failure I maybe
should overcorrected and not embraced it
that much because for the next four or
five years I put myself in any possible
acting situation good or bad so that I
not like porn but
like not like porn but like any kind of
opportunity to to to grow as a as an
actor and stuff like that and I had a
lot of fun doing that but that one thing
changed everything when I when I got did
you never work in that City again I
actually did work in that City again
ards